ouais notreb aujourd'hui fait du jour
des jours vous n'avez pas pu louper les
images de la visétat du roi Charles I en
France accompagné de Camila visite
d'État qui s'est poursuivi aujourd'hui
et qui se poursuivra encore demain le
couple royal britannique se rendra à à
Bordeaux on va en parler c'est
incroyable ça a fait des scores
incroyables dans les JT sur les chaînes
info finalement on aime bien les
couronnes on aime bien les être couronné
en France voici un extrait si vous navez
si vous avez passé à côté de ces images
je sais pas comment vous avez fait mais
extrait le voyez l'arrivée il y a
quelques secondes du roi Charles II du
roi Charles I du roi Charles II avec
Camilla le roi Charles II le roi Charles
I et Camila le roi Charles I arrive en
France alors ça c'était les arrivées de
du du roi Charles II aujourd'hui il
était au Sénat bonjour Jérémy merci
d'être avec nous vous êtes directeur
adjoint de la rédaction tion de la revue
coer euh il y avait un programme très
très très mimitré effectivement pour le
couple royal Charles I s'est exprimé ce
matin au Parlement il a poursuivi sa
journée est allé à la la cathédrale
basilique saint-unis également cet
après-midi il était encore avec Emmanuel
Macron enfin il y a tout un programme
c'est millimétr on a vu évidemment le
dîner à Versailles hier pourquoi et
c'est la question à laquelle on va
essayer de répondre pourquoi pourquoi
nous les Français sommes-nous tant
passionné par la Couronne britannique
ouis ou vous avez 5 he pour la réponse
ça depuis longtemps depuis longtemps
mais aujourd'hui il y a je crois la
fascination et c'est ça ça a quelque
chose à voir avec l'état de de de nos
démocraties aujourd'hui on est fasciné
par quelqu'un qui soit au-dessus de la
politique je pense que nos politiques
nous déçoivent tellement que quelqu'un
qui est là qui s'intéresse à nous qui
s'intéresse à la plan Anette mais qui
n'est pas là pour se faire élire pour
nous séduire et cetera et CER oui mais
nous on a coupé la tête de notre on a un
fait révolutionnaire en 1793 et on se
passionne de l'actualité des têtes
couronnées TR est est-ce qu'il y a pas
est-ce qu'il y a pas un effet the crown
parce que moi par exemple à titre
personnel la famille d'Angleterre
c'était vraiment pas ma priorité et
maintenant que j'ai vu la série the
crown si je croise le roi je vais dire
épisode 3 jou oui c'était une forme
d'hypnose subtile
oui ça ça ça a marché ça a marché sans
doute euh mais il y a aussi le fait
que aujourd'hui il y a ce drame de la
disparition de la reine qui était
tellement âgée donc tout le monde savoir
est-ce que Charles est-ce qu'il va
pouvoir la suivre est-ce qu'il va
pouvoir endosser regarder la fin de la
der je savais pas pour la reine merci
pour le spoil Flor oui non parce que en
France on aime on aime bien dire un peu
dans les médias que on s'intéresse pas à
Charles et en fait c'est pas vrai la
semaine dernière Paris Match a titré
irremplaçable avec en une ellisabette et
parlait finalement assez peu du roi
Charles qui arrivait et il se trouve
qu'il passionne les Français ils étaient
9 millions à le regarder quand il a été
couroné c'était plus que pour les
obsèques de la reine ellisabeth et là on
va en parler les audiences et et cetera
depuis qu'il est à Paris depuis qu'il
est en France c'est costaud donc donc
voilà les Français aiment le RO c'est
peut-être à cause de the Cr mais les
Français aiment le roi Charles II et et
14 millions sur la BBC hein également de
de téléspectateurs mais quand même quand
on regarde les les de presse ce matin on
a jeté un petit coup d'œil à la presse
pour voir quelle été la tonalité quand
on va sur la presse britannique on se on
s'aperçoit qu' y a pas un mot ou
quasiment pas une ligne on va voir
quelques unees que nous avons
sélectionné The Guardian notamment qui
est voilà qui est euh qui s'arrête sur
des des des spécificités très très
britanniques pas un mot de la visite
d'État du du roi on en a sélectionné
plusieurs le mirror également il y a pas
une ligne nous on en France Le Parisien
Aujourd'hui en France effectivement on a
parlé ce matin mais c'est pas en pleine
en pleine une ça a été évoqué aussi dans
le dans le Figaro mais en
Grande-Bretagne cette visite d'État
semble passer inaperçu oui parce que
nous on a un roi donc on dit oh c'est le
roi bah lui on le connaît hein mais vous
non donc c'est spécial en même temps on
en parle d'un point de vue strictement
politique et bien c'est c'est très bien
pour les relations franco-britanque
qu'il continue mais pas plus c'està dire
tout tout le glamour ça on connaît déjà
c'est très bien approuve mais on connaî
ou vous connaissez donc affaires
courantes de voir de voir le qui était
invité moi j'ai adoré me dire alors il y
a qui pourquoi Didier Drogba génial de
se dire je trouve ça marrant de se dire
pourquoi un tel il est et lui il est pas
invité j'ai regardé dans la boîte au let
si était vous avz non vous pas l' pasçu
non je pas reçu ah ben je en plus
j'aurais pu faire les moi mon rêve
c'était d'aller au dîner d'éteindre la
lumière et de leur faire c'est pas c'est
pas versaill ici ah si pardon je rallume
versa c'était versaill ici regardez
regardez libération
Charl par c'est pas mal c'est TRV
référence à la sérieine par pour ceux
qui s pour com regard quand même les
audiences des chaînes info notamment
hier et des JT ça a très très bien
marché et ça va certainement continuer
de de marcher aujourd'hui ça va
s'afficher sur sur votre écran notamment
BFM alors ça c'est l'édition spéciale de
de France 2 bon 16 21,4 % de de part de
de marché et puis sur les chaînes infos
BFM TV monté à 1 million de
téléspectateurs à 19h un peu plus d'un
mlion 1on à 19h50 hier passion pour
cette couronne britannique oui et j'ai
je pense une révélation à faire qui va
vous plaire parce que évidemment le roi
devait venir en France en premier mais
il a dû aller en Allemagne oui mais à
cause de
laation la réformme retraites mais
attention donc en Allemagne il a fait un
tabac il a fait un tabac on l' ad il
vendit des cl c'est vraiment une
première il n'était pas aussi berlinois
que ça mais il a fait un tabac il a des
ancêtres allemands d'accord mais je
crois qu'on peut dire qu'il a fait un
tabac encore plus grand ici mais
pourquoi vous dites ça pourquoi
qu'est-ce que sur qu sur quoi vous vous
basez pour pouvoir affirmer ça ah mais
sur sur sur
l'audienceud absument et la ferveur que
j'ai on dit les choses depuis le décès
de sa maman tout le monde la reine
ellisabeth 2 tout le monde s'interrogaer
se demandait quel successeur il allait
être c'est vrai que là aussi même les
Français 60 % des Français s'étaient dit
attristés de la du décès d'Élisabeth II
finalement il semble remporter le Paris
non tout à fait tout à fait mais je
reviens à ce que vous disiez tout à
l'heure de du programme chronométré
parce que si on étudie ce programme qui
est tellement riche on voit bien que
pour lui la France est spéciale la
France est différente il veut consacrer
le plus de de temps d'énergie possible
àur C c'était la France qui devait être
le premier pays qui devait visiter après
avoir été est couronné malheureusement
il avait pas pu venir voilà pour pour
les raisons qu'on a évoqué quelques
inconvénients oui et on lui a découvert
l'humour moi j'ai écouté ce matin donc
toutes les information et il y a une
punchline qui est magnifique où il dit
d'ailleurs il dit vous en France vous
avez du vin nous en Angleterre on a de
l'humour on a tous besoin des uns des
autres je trouve ça génial et de se dire
le côté sritige qui était génial oui
mais en plus plus on boit du vin plus on
devient drôle ou alors avec modération
s'il vous plaît on pas de problème merci
beaucoup tout va bien Floriant l'un de
ces grands défis au roi on le sait c'est
de conquérir la jeunesse de son pays
parce que il y a 7 anglais sur 10 qui
considèrent que la monarchie est
ringarde et ne s plus à rien et en fait
il voulait vraiment venir en France en
premier surtout pour ça parce que la
France voilà quand on est en Angleterre
ça fait ça peut faire brancher ça peut
faire ça peut aller dans dans son sens
et là j'ai une petite info à vous donner
on l'a vu beaucoup s'afficher avec avec
certains joueurs de football avec le
président du parissgermain et le
parisgermain a communiqué sur sa venue
il va signer là-bas il va pas signer
mais il s'est intéressé il s'est
intéressé à la Fondation PSG et il s'est
intéressé surtout à un club qui est
extrêmement populaire chez les jeunes et
chez les jeunes en Angleterre ils ont 70
millions d'abonnés sur insta c'est peu
près l'ensemble des trois plus gros
clubs londoniens euh en Angleterre donc
pour lui et c'est lui ça ça a pas été
dit qui à l'initiative de cette
rencontre il se murmure au PSG que c'est
Macron lui-même qui lui aurait soufflé
parce que Macron a visité cette
fondation il y a quelques mois il avait
été conquis par par l'ambition de cette
fondation qui vient notamment en aide
aux enfants en difficulté ce murmure qui
sera sur Europe 2 demain
matinis pasis pas le dire donc je te
voilà il faut quand même rendre hommage
à à à l'état français et aussi peut-être
pour une fois je ne sais pas mais à
Monsieur Macron parce qu'ils ont mis le
paquet eux-mêmes ils ont vraiment
investi beaucoup et cet accueil c'est
vraiment non dé plais des
révolutionnaires c'est un accueil royal
bien sûr mais alors justement que
pensez-vous de ce dîner réception à
versaill hier évidemment c'est c'est
décrié on a parlé du vin notamment les
bouteilles de
vin bon comment c'est vu outre outre
manche c'est normal quoi oui oui tout à
fait c'est normal on chez nous ça ça c
un peu mais autrement c'est normal on
sait que c'est c'est ces personnages
importants ils font ça par devoir mais
le le plus remarquable hier c'est qu'on
a ignoré le protocole on a commencé en
retard on a fini très tard houtehour et
et ce ce départ par rapport au programme
h chronométré ça c'est très positif à
mon avis et et là aussi il y a une
volonté de plaire aux jeunes parce que
on voit que ce dîner c'était aussi un
show people parce qu'il y avait eu
grande qui éta là il y avait Charlotte
ginbourg il y avait Mick Jager et le
seul média vidéo français accrédité pour
filmer cet événement c'était gala donc
un magazine people qui a diffusé ça sur
TikTok il a eu plus de 2 3000 millions
de vues c'est eux qui l'ont vendu
ensuite aux chaînes info et cetera et ça
aussi il se dit que le le le roi était
au courant et que c'est quelque chose
qui a été voulu parce que une
destination de de de de lecteurs de de
téléspectateurs d'un jeune public voilà
particulier donc ça aussi il y a cette
volonté de dépoussiierer vraiment les
visites protocolaires voilà dépoussierer
les couronnes britanniques moi moi je
trouve tout tout ceci tellement gênantou
ah moi ça me dérange par que c'est un
peu me dérange c'est indécent c'est un
peu indécent moi selon Mo
vu voilà la situation économique et tout
actuelle moi ça me dérange je pense que
c'est plutôt un bon
investissement parce que la somme
despensé par rapport à la dette
française et est presque inexistante
mais les investissements qui vont
conduire à des relation commerciale ça
va enrichir tout le monde ça ne
tiendrait qu'à moi j'aurais ramené une
addition au milieu de la table en disant
monsieur le roi on partage on partage
chacun met ce qu'il peut voà vraiment
c'est le pour boire oui ben tant mieux
on a bien besoin non non mais c'est
important effectivement de réchauffer qu
quel est l'état des relations entre le
couple royal et Emmanuel Macron et
Brigitte Macron est-ce qu'on sait mais
d'après ce qu'on voit selon le langage
corporel comme on dit les relations sont
excellentes non mais bon attendez
attendez attendez ils ont toutes les
caméras du mond braqué sur eux c'est
normal qu'ils affichent une entente
cordiale est-ce que vraiment euh je ne
suis pas t avec vous parce que le
langage corporel parle et même avec
toutes les caméras du monde s'il y a
quelque chose qui ne va pas ça se voit à
à 15 km à la onde donc on voit très bien
qui qu' se plaisent ensemble on joue au
pingpong ensemble mais c'est presque
comme un camping
quoi c'est c'est tout ça c'est ce qu'on
appelle en anglais à lin d'accord il y a
de l'amour j'ai pas vu le pingpong et le
camping j'ai pas tout vu non plus oui on
vous a préservé de
certaines merci à vous moi je suis pas
du tout d'accord je suis plutôt d'accord
avec le titre du monde qui parle d'E du
journal Le Monde qui parle d'une mise en
scène et d'une entente cordiale parce
que il se voit surtout pour essayer de
réparer ce qui peut encore l'être après
le brexit et je suis pas sûr que ce soit
les meilleurs amis du monde et je suis
pas sûr que l'ambiance soit aussi
chaleureuse et bien je pense que vous
avez tort et je pense que l'histoire me
donnera
raison on est en train de sebrouiller la
demain
monsieurz-moi s'il vous plaît moi je
voudrais qu'on regarde quand même ce qui
s'est dit sur les réseaux sociaux parce
que votre avis nous intéresse évidemment
il y a eu beaucoup beaucoup
effectivement d'images qui ont été
tourné en éésion beaucoup de de
commentaires on va peut-être commencer
par par le le premier tweet alors que
dit-il transfert validé pour Charles
voilà on en parlait qui portera les
couleurs du PSG on en parlait tout à
l'heure regardez cette cette image
effectivement c'est un boom voilà avec
un boom qui est qui est affiché pareil
on a retrouvé le le président autre
tweet on a retrouvé le président le roi
en
après leur dîner des à à versaill
regardez cette photo qui a été
publiéeeur c'est ça il y a pas mal
d'humour là-dedans aussi sur les réseaux
sociaux voilà c'est ces photos qui qui
ont été détourné et et regardez alors ça
aussi on adore pour les Parisiens qui
râent tout le temps parce qu'il y a des
embouteillages certains se sont exprimés
VI a cette photo que disentil voilà il y
a des nombreuses rues de Paris qui
étaient interdite à la circulation à
l'occasion de la visite et regardez il
annidalgo et certains constatent il a
pas de problème où sont les
embouteillages ouais benah je je je
prends très rarement la voiture j'ai dû
emmener mon chat hier j'ai je vais
rarement paril en voiture je l'ai fait
hier je sais pas pourquoi j'ai mis uneh
45 faire 2 km j'avais oublié que le roi
venait donc la prochaine fois tu peux
envoyer un petit SMS ouis il vous
prendra dans sa voiture ou merci
beaucoup voilà on aimerait voilà
regardez effectivement les les autres
tweets peut-être un autre tweet des
internautes qui auraient aimé voir une
autre photo que celle du président
Macron avec Charles 3 ça aussi c'est
détourné il y a il y a beaucoup d'humour
beaucoup d'imagination à chaque fois sur
les réseaux non je sais pas pas sûr on
va aller vérifier l'information Clément
je sais pas si c'est un montage qui a
fait ce ce montage c'est assz c'est
assez amusant et puis souvenez ça oui
oui on me dit c'est un internaute dans
l'oreillet de s
blague pardon excusez-moi c'est ça
génial le roi a annulé sa première
visite pardon à la suite des
manifestations de la réforme des
retraites ceux qui n'ont pas oublé ce
qui n'ont pas oublié regarder certains
internautes on voit
effectivement le roi et Emmanuel Macron
qui enterre cet arbre et o il disent on
enterre n nos retraites voilà il y a
aussi des des messages
h à ce nià on s'use beaucoup
effectivement sur les réseaux sociaux de
de cette visite finalement même sur les
réseaux sociaux on est passionné par
cette cette couronne britannique c'est
c'est par et pareil pour les funérailles
de laarinene ça avait fait des cartons
d'audience c'était en septembre c'était
il y a un an ces funérailles d'Élisabeth
I qui le monde entier il y en a des bons
à chaque fois il y a des gens qui
regardent l'ctu juste pour dire ok
qu'est-ce que je peux mettre de drôle et
voilà hashtag ça et voilà et c'est c'est
ce qui nous fait marer oui non c'est ce
qui nous fait marer voilà ben nous on
aime bien et on vous les passe
effectivement dans dans PAF tous ces
tous ces extrraits regardez les
funérailles d'éizabeth 2 18 millions et
demi de de de de
téléspectateurs au total et 7 millions
et demi en France ça c'était pour la BBC
et nous 7 millions et demi de de
téléspectateurs la Couronne britannique
qui continue de de passionner les
mariages aussi les mariages royaux euh
effectivement font couler beaucoup d' et
nos journaux adore raconter les
histoires on est plus Harry Harry et
Méane ça bouge plus hein les histoiresf
on est friante ça c'est ça aussi je
pense que l'attachement enfin
l'attachement ce qui ce que les gens
aiment aussi avec le RO char c'était
c'est quand même un roi assez
irrévérentieux qui a jamais
véritablement respecté le protocole qui
a toujours eu des des histoires
scabreuses ne serait-ce qu'avec sa
nouvelle pour le
mariage typique d'un roi les rois ils
sont comme ça c'estàdire il sont chauds
oui exactement ils ne sont pas là pour
obéir à toutes les règles will
William a l'air d'être plutôt sage si
c'est qui votre préféré donnons-lui le
temps dons le temps ou alors on ne le
sait pas encore il y en a qui vont trop
loin à mon avis mais on en parle pas oui
et et Harry comment est-il perçu
maintenant outrem manche est-ce que
c'est toujours le le chouchou des
Britanniques ou Harry ou William har
Harry ah Harry il est est
auat gr grill oui oui tout à fait tout à
fait parce que les Britanniques lui
pardonn écart mais là c'est terminé ou
mais non parce que on peut avoir des
écarts mais se mettre dans une position
une posture où on critique euh justement
la main qui vous donne à manger ça non
ouais en France c'est le préféré parce
que justement il a cassé un peu les
codes en se disant je suis né dans cette
famille royale je vais même si je suis
né là je vais faire ce qui me PL dans
COD c'est une chose une hypocrisie
flagrante ça c'est une est-ce qu'il a
pas juste choisi l'amour ou oh là là
c'est
joliment on verra si ça dure l'amour ah
oui oui oui c'est ça vous vous vous
dites ça voilà ça finira mal vousê
romantique c'est ça je crois qu'on me
drag c'est très
gênant alors que c'est vrai
effectivement les deux frères qui sont
très très différents aimable mais il y a
des limites quand même monsieur ils sont
très différents les deux frères
finalement très différent on a William
qui rentre complètement dans dans le
rang Kate aussi enfin Kate a rien à dire
en fait sur irréprochable irréproch ah
oui et et et et le couple est plus à à à
à une meilleure côte de popularité que
le roi lui-même donc tout le monde les
adore ça c'est ça c'est extra mais ils
ne commettent aucune faute bah oui il ne
commettent aucune faute c'est c'est un
SF jusque- là est-ce que ça va mieux
entre les deux frères vous savez ou pas
euh je non pour de vrai he parce que pas
ça ne va pas ça ne va pas bien
non et il faudra attendre longtemps
avant que les choses changent ou la
rupture et c'est comme ça dans les
familles parfoisou en Angleterre oasis
regardez le groupe Oasis
frères
anglais concurence local est local entre
har ah ben Liam c'est celui qui fait les
bêtises donc ça doit êre AR oui je crois
je suis d'accord oui et la visite demain
à Bordeaux 3 jours 3 jours le le roi
aura tout fait avec Camila et puis on a
vu Camila aussi très proche aussi de
Brigitte
Macron ils ont eu des S ont eu des
activités communes aujourd'hui oui oui
oui ou bièque national en fait d'après
ce conseil de ces deux femmes d'après
leur leur situation il y a beaucoup de
monde qui se moque qui critiqu mais
elles ont l'air d'être toutes les deux
des femmes très sympathiques très
sympathiques et qui font des efforts
et qui ont toutes les raisons de de
s'entendre visiblement l'amitié
franco-britannique est au beauau fix
grâce notamment à cette visite d'État
dont on va continuer de parler
évidemment avec Cyril PMP merci beaucoup
à tous d'être venu sur le plateau de de
Paf
aujourd'hui pa le je c'est tout de suite